-Jeremy Allen White.
Jeremy, welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-Thank you for coming.
You're not the first
family member
to be
in "The Tonight Show" world.
To be at "The Tonight Show."
-That's right. Yeah.
I think you always want
your children to outshine you.
I just didn't know it was gonna
happen this early.
My 3-year-old daughter, Ezer,
came here, what,
like two months ago, six weeks
ago or something like that
and got to hang out with you.
-Dakota Johnson is
her godmother?
-Yeah, Dakota's her godmother.
And she's a really big fan of
Angel Moon, which is this...
-Chris Martin.
-Puppet in Coldplay's new album.
-They have like a muppet band
called The Weirdos.
-The Weirdos. Yeah.
-And they're all muppets.
-They're all muppets.
-And they're from space.
-They were on the show.
It wasn't even Chris, really.
-No, they were booked on
the show, yeah.
And then this beautiful little
baby was walking around
with Dakota, and she was like,
"Angel Moon, Angel Moon."
She was, like, so cute. And she
was like -- I go, "Oh, my gosh."
Like, no one could stop
looking at this kid.
-Yeah.
-Somebody took a picture of me
doing our exchange,
I want to say.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Look at that hair.
-I did not know
it was your baby.
That's Adam Sandler's
Hawaiian shirt.
-Oh, nice.
[ Laughter ]
Man, she's met Adam Sandler,
too.
She's really like --
[ Laughter ]
-She had a great --
-Really shining, man.
-She's welcome back whenever.
-Cool.
-I'm happy that you're here,
because man, oh, man, did I hear
more about this show
than anything on Earth.
"The Bear."
-"The Bear."
-Everyone -- It's almost like --
I don't know if the Internet was
finding me or thinking that
I would be really into it.
But everybody's like, "You got
to watch 'The Bear.'
It's the must-see show."
I'm like, "I get it.
'The Bear.' What is it about?
Is it about a bear?
What is going on?"
I had no clue what it's about.
It's like, no, it's about
a restaurant in Chicago.
-Yes.
-I go, "Okay.
I still have nothing to do
with Chicago."
I like food. Fine.
-Yeah, food.
It sounds like you'll like it.
Yeah.
-It doesn't. Why?
[ Laughter ]
I have no connection.
I love it.
-You love it?
-The Internet was right.
-Oh, good.
-Everyone who told me was right.
It's like 100% on
Rotten Tomatoes.
-It's doing really well, man.
-You crush it.
How do we explain it
to everyone?
It's very fast.
I will say, it moves fast.
You could probably binge this
in a weekend.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's like 4 1/2 hours.
It's eight episodes.
And I think we were trying to
capture, like, the pace
of a kitchen, which is
really, really intense.
And the show is about a young
chef, Carmen Berzatto,
coming home to Chicago
after working in these, like,
really intense kitchen
environments all over the world.
And he comes home, and he
kind of inherits his family's
sandwich shop after his brother
passes away.
So he comes back, and he's --
he's trying to kind of, like,
bring this shop to
a different sort of glory.
And he's also dealing with
the death of his brother.
-Yeah. People are loving, also,
the attention to detail
in this show.
And I will say, that right
there -- anyone who -- Yeah.
-That's a deli, is what they
call it, right there.
-If you drink out of that
plastic deli thing --
That's what chefs drink out of.
-You're the real deal.
-Did you do your homework
for that?
Like, how did you realize that?
-Yeah.
So, we did a lot of work.
I spent a lot of time
in kitchens.
The kitchen I spent the most
time at was a restaurant
in L.A. called Pasjoli.
It's in Santa Monica.
Chef Dave Beran is chef there.
He's really incredible.
They have a star --
a Michelin star,
which is kind of like
the biggest deal
in the restaurant world.
-Did people know who you are
at the time,
before "The Bear" came out?
-So, we were all in masks.
I was in the kitchen.
It's an open kitchen.
So it was kind of fine.
And I liked that I could be
there, you know.
Everybody was like,
"This is just some actor."
And they didn't really give it
any thought.
The show hadn't come out.
They didn't know anything
about the show, so I felt very,
like, you know, safe there.
-Yeah.
-But yeah, yeah.
We did all our homework. And we
had these wonderful chefs.
Matty Matheson, who's a really
incredible chef,
Courtney Storer, who's the
showrunner's sister, was a chef
at this place
Jon & Vinny's in L.A.
So that authenticity that came
from these guys.
-I've had it.
-Yeah, that place is great.
-Yeah. So good.
-I went to a place called
Mr. Beef,
I want to say, in Chicago.
-Yeah. That's where we shoot.
-I was there. I'm in that place.
-Oh, my God.
Is your face up on the wall?
-I think my face is on the wall.
-Your face is probably
on the wall.
-I think I am on the wall.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-Oh, I hope I don't take you
out of character
next time you're doing this.
-I know.
I'm just going to make eye
contact with you as I'm --
-You're like, "Look, they let
any moron in this place."
You throw a drink at the picture
and have it splash off me.
But I'd love to make a cameo.
-Sweet.
-Yeah. I want to show everyone
a clip of "The Bear."
Check this out.
-Time to try the new sandwiches.
Behind. Order!
Marcus, rolls, please, Chef.
[Bleep] Again.
That's crumbly. It's too dense.
-Doing it by hand.
-Yo.
-It's the mixer.
-It's not the mixer, alright?
It's crumbly.
The oven's too dry.
You need to fill a baking sheet
with water,
put it on the oven floor,
throw in another batch, okay?
-Don't tell me how to do my job.
-Just do it.
Yo!
Somebody come try this, cousin.
-Yeah, right!
-That was done perfect.
-There you go, Chef.
Chef.
What's going on?
What do you think?
-It's redundant and white,
just like you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Redundant and white,
just like -- yes, chef!
Jeremy Allen White.
Season one of "The Bear" is
streaming right now on Hulu.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Angel Olsen.
Stick around.